keeping the hope for change alive
Lebanese returned to the central beirut
square where calls for a new leadership
rang out six months ago they're back in
the streets after a lockdown to contain
the spread of coronavirus was eased
weeks of closures hurt an already
collapsing economy there is uncertainty
about the future as unemployment rises
I'm 33 years old I have been graduated
from the University like 10 years ago
and a person like me should be an a
senior position right away so it's
because the overall economic situation
which was caused by the subsequent
governments Lebanon has already
defaulted on its debt for the first time
in history we have called for the World
Bank and I am asked to give us loans
again to put us under even larger public
debt and privatizing the whole state and
I don't think that can help prices of
basic goods have increased by more than
50 percent while the local currency the
lira has depreciated by at least 60
people's incomes and savings have lost
value and the people are still paid the
same in the Lebanese lira 30 percent of
registered companies have closed and the
Labor Ministry says 20 percent have
reduced employee salaries by half the
dismissal of workers and the closure of
organizations have been the biggest
concerns the ministry has put forward a
plan to solve huge unemployment and to
protect the rights of workers but that
will need money and the government has
been unable to provide for the most
basic needs as the state nears
bankruptcy
some people fear the country is sliding
into chaos the middle class is becoming
poor government figures show up to 75
percent of a nation of 5 million people
need help while 45 percent live below
the poverty line Human Rights Watch is
warning more than half of Lebanon's
people are at the risk of going hungry
the government may be promising better
days ahead but it admits the road will
not be easy
XANA Hodor al jazeera Beirut